今日は第五章です それで
あの 今まで あの 我々は心っていうのはある流れとしてBeatですか
この道ですか この流れとして見ていたんです
ということは この個体的にこれは心ですよと
この心で私たちは考えてますよという概念はないんですね
だから心という何か主体があって
そのものがいろんな行動をしているんだというふうな概念はなかったと思います
で 心っていうのは瞬間生まれて瞬時に消える
で 生まれた瞬間で何か一つその仕事をして消えちゃう
で また次に心が生まれて
違う仕事をして それで消えちゃう
ですから 一つの流れなんですね
ですから 主体はないということで
で 私はいつでも例えるのはこの噴水とか川とかね
そういうものにいつでも例えますから
噴水という あの 主体がないんですね
水が流れているだけ それに我々は
まあ噴水という ただ言葉でラベルをラベリングしているだけです
ですから この心という心は主体で見るべきではない
人間の我として 魂として見るべきではない
それに何か変化しない
何か主体のようなものがずっとあって
それはすべての行動をしているんだというふうな
この単純な考え方は仏教ではないんです
それは考え方のレベルから見れば
ずいぶん単純なんですね
で 例えばあるうちに人がいると
その人が全部やってるんだと
そういうふうに考えるのはすごい単純なんです
だから誰がやってるんですかと聞きたくなるんですね
で 例えば政府がこの仕事をやってると言ったら
政府は主体になります
政府って一体何ですか？仕事自体はある特定の仕事があって
それは政府がやるといっても
ある一人の人がやるんであって
じゃあその人が政府ですかと
全く違うでしょうに 例えば
まあ我々はちょっと税金ごまかしちゃったと
それでまあ税務署から人が来て
それを調べて まあ罰金を決めちゃうんだと
罰金決めちゃうんだと
それで私たちはまあ政府が罰金決めたと言うんですね
でも政府は決めたわけじゃないんです
自分のうちに来た税務署の役員がそれはやったんですね
それでその人が政府ですかと言えば
全くそうじゃないんですね
ただの一人の人間であって
私たちとは何の違う 何の権限も何も持ってないんです
一人の人間だけなんですね
ですから じゃあ一体政府って何ですかと探してみると
たくさん人々が出てくるんですね
国会の人々やら公務の人々
あれは政府ですよと 本当にそれは政府ですかと
考えてみれば その人々は何の力もないんですね
そうすると国民がいるんだから
その人々は選ばれていて
国民の雇い主になっちゃうんです
雇われている人間になっちゃうんです
そうすると政府は何です？誰ですか？と
国民になっちゃうんですね
そうすると自分たちが政府になるでしょうに
そこで理屈は崩れちゃうんですね
政府は罰金決めたっていうことは
それだったら 私は私で私に罰金決めたっていうことにもなるんですね
ですから 主体はそちらもないんです
僕は言いたがっているのは
普通の世俗的なところ
例を見て考えたっても
政府という主体はないんです
ただ いろいろ働きしている人々を組み合わせたところで
我々は大雑把に政府という
その政府ということは
その時その時変わっちゃうんですね
ある時は総理大臣 政府になっちゃうし
ある時は国会そのものが政府になっちゃうし
ある時は国会と公務員みんなまとめて政府になっちゃうし
ある時はもう日本全体みんな政府になっちゃうし
ですから主体はないんですね
それで主体探そうというのは何か一つそのものを探すことなんですね
ですから 私が言いたいのは
じゃあ政府という実体を探してみてくださいと
これは政府の本物だ これは真髄だと
これなければ政府は成り立ちませんと
という何か一つありますかね
ないでしょう 誰を抜けたっても政府は成り立ちますから
総理大臣のあなたいりませんだから出て行ってくださいと言ったっても
日本はそれで滅びるわけじゃないし
で そういうことなんです
もし まあ一応ありえない話なんですけど
もし我々こういうことを仮定しましょう
日本の国会が全部消えちゃったと
それで日本国も消えるんですかね
全くなくたっても まあみんなお互いに平和でいると思いますよ
自分たちで自分の身を守っていると思いますけど
その時もやっぱり政府っていうものはあるんです
ですから この心は何ですかとか
魂はどこにあるか どんなものかと探すのは
そっちにしたこの人間の考え方が間違いなんです
政府の実態を探すことと同じなんです
政府という働きは確実にあるんですけど
それも大雑把な言い方で
我々知ってるのは まあそういう法律はあるとかね
法律で言ったっても 法律を犯さない限りあるかないかもわからないしね
関係ない それはテキストに書いてあるものだけで
人が何かおかしいことしてやったら
まあそれはそれなりに
じゃあ法律でそれなりの誰かがそういう調べるだけで
じゃあその人が法律ですかというと
全然そうじゃないんです
私たち法律を犯した頃
どこかで審判受けちゃうと
ある裁判官が我々を調べるんだと
で 彼が決めるので あなた方はなんとかなんとかの法律を破りましたから
こういうこういう罰を決めますと
ただ その瞬間で その人
すごい法律そのものに見えちゃいますけど
その人にそんな権利何もないんです
ただ自分が自分の仕事をしているだけで
もしその人の判決が間違ってならば
違うところでまたあれはダメですよと言われちゃうし
そこで あの法律作るのが国会であって
だから裁判官の立場から見れば
国会の方が一番偉いんですね
法律を決めることやら消すことやら全部勝手にできるんだから
本当にそうですかと言えば
もし国会の人が法律を犯したらどうなるんですかね
それでも捕まりますから
で 何のこともないんです
平気で捕まって あんたこういう法律を犯しましたと
だから誰もそこの主体がなくなっちゃうんですね
主体がなくなっちゃいますけど
法律という なんとなくだ働きはあるんです
じゃあ誰がそれやってるんですかね？誰が法律守って厳しくこれ監視
監視しているんですか？誰もないでしょうに
日本の裁判の裁判 まあ一番偉い人は何て言いますかね
いますけど いろいろ裁判
いろいろレベルあるでしょ
二審裁判 最高裁判所長官
長官とかそういう人がいるかもしれません
じゃあその人は法律の守る一番大きな総長ですか？全くないんです
彼が自分に与えられている義務だけ果たそう
それ以上何の実力もないんです
だから結局誰にも力がないんです
ないんだけど やっぱり力があるんです
でも誰にない 人にはないということなんです
主体はないということ
ですから 普通の我々の世界を見ても
主体がないということは見えるはずなんです
で この考え方なんですね
人間はすぐ誰か偉い人を目指しているんですから
で 例えば私に私を管理している誰かが目上の人がいるんですね
で そこだけの関係で私がまあ全てを管理している一番最高な誰かがいるだろうと馬鹿げたことを考えちゃう
それだけのことを 例えば私が何か悪いことしちゃったら
警察の人々をしてもう大変厳しく叱られたりすると
それで私はこの人は私より偉いんだと
この人よりももっと偉い人がいるんだと
その人よりももっと偉い人がいるんだ
その人よりもっと偉い人がいるんだと
そう言っておいた最後の一番究極的な偉い人がいるだろうと考えるんだことは可能なんですけど
実際はそういう人はいない
正しい考えちゃうと 別に誰でも偉く偉いわけじゃないんです
私が悪いことしたら 警察の人に叱られてても
もしその人の叱り方が間違っていたならば
その場で私にその人を訴える権利があるんです
あなたの名前を言ってくださいと
今日訴えますと 同じ警察庁に行って訴えられるんです
だから誰も偉く偉くわけじゃないんです
まあ単なるその時の相互関係で
そういうことになりたくだけ
ですから この仏教の思考っていうのは
そういうふうに考えているんですから
一般の人々の思考とはそこら辺ではもう変わってるんです
変わってるっていうことは間違ってるではなくて
一般の世界の人々の考え方はあまりにも単純すぎなんですね
ですから 悪い例で言うならば
井戸の中の蛙がまあこれは世界だと言ってることと同じで
我々みんな我々に見える範囲は小さいんですね
人間には ですから その見える小さい範囲で全てのことに結論出そうとする
そこでこの間違いは犯しますと
ですから この この なんでこの心のpathですか
このチッタ ビージャですか
そういうものを言ったんですかというと
この えーと 主体はないということを説明するために言ったものなんです
心という主体はないんだと
その瞬間に その瞬間で心が生まれて消えてしまう
その一つ一つの心にそんなに大事な大変な力あるわけじゃないんです
見るということを起こるとこは
見る心が生まれて そこで消えちゃう
何の力もないんです その心に
次の心にこの見たものを判断しちゃったら
判断してそれで消えてしまっちゃうんです
自分の仕事をして それで終わりと
他の管理することは何もできないと
それでこのどこに我が生まれるか
この人間にはね この概念がね
私がいるんだと 生まれるかという質問にもそこに答えがあるんですね
政府はどこにありますか？という質問と同じなんです
政府という働きがあるかといえばあるんですけど
じゃあどこにありますか？誰ですか？と
まああのイギリスの法律システムだったら
政府っていうのは総理大臣ですけど
ですから 自分の国でも法律は昔からイギリス風にあったんだから
まあたまに総理いろいろ問題が出てきたらI am the governmentと言うんです
法律的に総理大臣にI am the governmentいきなり怒鳴って言うんだけど
本当に総理が政府ですかと
じゃなくて 彼をまた同じく認めなくて
私は選ばれたんだと国民に Selected Selected
じゃない elected
ですね ですから 国民にあんた嫌ですよと思っちゃったらそれで終わります
それで結局政府は国民になっちゃうんですね
そうすると 政府は誰ですかと聞く質問自体をバカバカしくなっちゃうんですね
ある国民の一人が私は政府を探してるんだと
見つかるわけじゃないんです
ですから 人が私は修行してもう真我を探してるんだと
見つからないんです もし誤解がある限り
これはそうだろうという誤解ではいられますけど
例えば国会は政府だろうとかね
それは誤解であって 分析してみたら国会は政府でなくなっちゃうんです
それで国民は政府だって言っちゃったら
そこで定義消えちゃうんです
なぜならば 政府というのは国民を管理して支配してコントロールする機関は政府なんです Government
だから 僕は一応英語で考えて喋ってますけど
英語ではgovernmentと言うんですね
ですからgoverning body is the government
コントロールする主体がgovernmentで政府であると
だから国民をコントロールする主体がgovernmentであるならば
探してみれば国民がgovernmentになっちゃいますから
そこであの定義消えてしまうでしょうに
そういうことで この無我論というのは難しいんですけど
人間に理解するのは なぜならば人間
私ですよ 我ですよというのも
それなりの働きがあります
政府という働きもありますが
主体はないと 私に殴ったと言えば
それは嘘じゃないし もし殴られたならば
私は痛かったと言った場合は
別にそこで嘘を言っているわけじゃないんです
その人が痛かったんだから
自分にできるだけの知識で喋ってるだけ
でもそこに痛かった私という主体がありますかと探すとにないんです
痛かった私はいません
ただ痛かっただけ ですから分析してみると
その人は自分の体のどこに殴ったかと探さなくちゃいけない
それで手に顔に殴ったと
そこで顔に殴ったならば顔が痛いんであって
私は痛いわけじゃないんです
そこで本当に顔が痛いかというと
それも顔に神経とかなんとか流れていなきゃ痛みはないんです
顔が麻痺していると ぶん殴ったっても知らないんだから
それで神経あっただけで痛いかというとそうでもないんです
そこでその情報 脳細胞に行かなきゃ痛くはないんですから
じゃあ脳細胞痛いんですか？って脳細胞にはそういう神経ないんですね
脳細胞はもう麻酔かけなくたっても手術できるんです
全然痛くないんだそうです
ですから この痛いという考え方を作るのは結局脳細胞なんです
そういう脳細胞は痛みは知らない
だから痛みって何ですかと
分析すると まあ何かここにすごい圧力かけられたところで
ちょっとした電気信号起きて
その電気信号脳に行って
それを判断して それは避けた方がいいということはそこで考えて
痛みとして結果を出す
じゃあその感覚は痛みにしようと
同じく場所に殴られた時は
これは気持ちいいことにしようとするでしょうに
殴られるたびに痛いわけじゃないでしょうに
だからそういうそれぞれの条件も怒って殴ったら痛くなくても痛いと感じちゃうし
すごく可愛くて愛情があって
ただ愛情の表現として殴っちゃったら全然気にしないし
だから痛みっていうのは存在するかと聞きたくはなるんです
同じ場所に同じ力で殴っても
その時その時 その人と殴られた人とか
そういう条件によって
それ痛みにするか 気持ちよかったにするかということもまた変わっちゃいますから
で そんなことは人は考えられませんし
そこまでは考えませんですから
単なるいきなり殴られた
痛かった 私は痛かったと言ってしまっちゃう
そこで私は痛かったということは
本人にとって実体的な経験だから
この真我を探すんです
痛かった私 私はどこにいるか
楽しかった私はどこにいるか
と その本物の私を探しちゃうんです
そこはまあ この宗教の探求の世界になってるんですね
だからもう大間違いなんですね
この探すもの探す道は
それをお釈迦様は説明してるんですね
だからもう残念ですけど
まあ道徳の世界でどんな宗教でもほぼ同じ道徳を言ってますけど
ただ道徳は論理的に成り立ってるかいないかっていうぐらいの差なんですね
例えば嘘を言うなっていうことは
キリスト教でも言うし
イスラム教でも言うし
仏教でも言うし どこどんな宗教でも言うんですね
宗教ない人も嘘言ってはいけないと言うんです
で なぜ嘘言ってはいけないかという
この論理的な構成の場合は
それぞれの宗教は自分たちの論理を持ってるんです
そういう差があるんだけど
道徳の世界では まあ宗教であろうか
哲学であろうか 普通の社会的な価値観であろうか
そんなに差がないんです
でも 教えの場合はね 特にお釈迦様の考え方とは
世の中のある普通の世界宗教とはもう合わないんです
どうしても同じものだと言ってほしければ言えるの一言葉
真我を探すと 本物の私は何ですかと
探す道だというならば
お釈迦様はそれを探したんだけど
で そこで答えとしては全く違う答えが出てくるんですね
他のみんな これは真我だよと定義持ってくるんです
キリスト教に聞いても
これは真我ですよと イスラム教に聞いたらこれは魂ですよと
ヒンドゥー教に聞けばこれは魂ですよと
いろいろ定義は出てきます
答えが 仏教が出てくる答えは無我ですよと
あなたですよという答えなんです
ないんだと 探したところで
ですからその考え方はそういうふうに正しく考えると
いわゆる客観的にきちんと分析してみると
無我論はわかります 自我という主体はないということはわかります
そこで自我がどこに生まれるかというと
例えば目で物を見る 見たものは感じる
感じたところで あ 私は見たというふうに言葉が出てくる
その感じるところで我が生まれるんです
我という概念が生まれる
我が生まれるんじゃなくて
ですから ヴェーダナーという仏教の皆様知ってる言葉なんですけど
これは英語でFeelingという
ヴェーダナー これ感覚なんですね
ヴェーダナーっていうのは
それ我々は六種類の感覚が生まれるんです
目で感覚が生まれる 耳で感覚が生まれる
鼻で味覚が生まれる 舌で味覚が生まれるし
体ではその観測 触の感覚が生まれるし
頭でも同じく感覚が生まれるんですね
考えることでも その感覚に対して人間に我という概念が生まれちゃうんです
で 人が手を触ったところで感じたならば
私を触れたと言えるんです
感じなかったら知らないんです
目を開けたところで見えたならば
私が見ましたと言えるんです
目を開けていたっても全然見えない場合は
その概念が生まれないんですね
見えたと 聞こえたという概念も生まれないんですね
ですから この認識する主体
あるいは自我というものは一つの概念であって
実体ではないんです ある働きに人間が言ってる概念なんです
それはどんな働きにこの概念を言うかということは誰も分析しない
でも結構わかってはいるんです
感覚ということは 特にヒンドゥー世界の哲学を探してみると
みんなこの自分が真我をどこに探すかというと
感覚の世界で探してるんですね
だからそこら辺はわかってはいるんです
心があるならば その感覚の世界にあるぞと
その中で目で見えただけ
それも我なんですけど
真我ではないでしょうと
だから夢中であることはわかってるんだから
音を聞いているのも我なんですけど
でも真我にはならないかもしれませんと言って
仏教とほとんど同じ言葉を使って
そういうのは否定するんです
目で見えるものもああだこうだ
そうではないと そうではないと
胃で感じるものは 直接感じるのは真我だよと言っちゃうんですね
そこで意識で一般的に人々が感じるものをまた否定するんです
一般的な人々 いろんなものを意識で考えている
あれは真我ではないんだと
人はバラバラだから ですから瞑想という言葉が出てきて
ちょっと超越した次元超えちゃって
そこで感じるものは真我だよと
で そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
やっぱり超越した知識であろうが
それは意で感じるものだと
感じるものは感覚であって
それは無常でしょうと
無常たるフィーリングを
無常たる受を 感覚を我にあらすと
我だとは言えないんだと
ですから すべてのものはそういう風に流れているんだ
無常であるんだ 流れということは無常ということなんですね
仏教用語ではその二つの言葉を使っているんです
で お釈迦様は無常という言葉を使っているし
この流れという言葉をそんな使ってないんだけど
でも哲学的に仏教を説明しなくちゃいけなくなった時代では
もう流れ流れという言葉をずっと使うようになったんですね
流れにパーリ語で言うのはサンティティなんです
一応前の授業の内容はだいたい目次で言いたがっていた
ずっとこの話はそういうことなんです
ですから 明確に認識の働きをすごいきめ細かく説明するんです
瞬間 例えば目で見えたと
チャックヴィンニャーナが生まれたと
それからサンパティッチェという心が生まれるんだと
それ心死んだところでサンティーラナという心が生まれるんだと
その心が死んじゃったらオッタパナという確定心という心が生まれるんだと
それ死んじゃったらちょっと似ている心が七つぐらいずっと流れちゃうんだと
生まれて死んで 生まれて死んで
それから有分身に落ちるんだと
それは見たということだと
そこで意識でまた人を考えた
私が見たと それ後から自我が生まれてくる
その瞬間で自我がないんです
見る瞬間で だから自我っていうのは後から追っかけてくる化け物に過ぎないんです
妄想概念に過ぎないんですね
ですから 自我は先にあるという宗教的な考え方ではなくて
自我真我っていうのはもともと本来あるんだっていうことではなくて
仏教から言えるのは 真我
自我っていうのは後から来る化け物だと
経験の後から人間作り出す化け物だと
幻覚だと 宗教の世界で言っているのは
本来は真我があったと
本来は如来心があったと
という概念なんです  [背景の物音]ですからこのたとえいくら仏教の世界だと言ったっても
その実体から説明しちゃうと仏教ではないんですね
ですから この三身論ですか
大乗仏教の始まりで生まれる三身論から大乗仏教哲学が発展しましたから
それまあその瞬間からもう仏教ではなくなっちゃうんです
三身論っていうのは何でしたっけ？法身と報身と法身と化身
いわゆる真理というものがあって
それは法身であって それで真理は菩薩たちやらそういう人々に現れる状態は応身であって
我々清浄仏教の連中には人間で見えなきゃ理解できないんだから
おバカもんだから人間で現れたんだと
ブッダそれは化け物だと
本物じゃないんだと そういう考え方なんですね
三身論というのは ですから
生きていたお釈迦様はもうひどい否定するんです
あれは幻覚だと 嘘だと
で そちらの哲学的な立場っていうのは
本来真実たる何かあるんだと
そこを変化させて幻想の世界が現れてるんだと
その思考自体が仏教から言えば全く違うんです
仏教は全く逆のことを言ってるんです
この人間の瞬間的な経験があって
その経験に基づいて自我があるんだと考える
ですから 自我が後から出てくる化け物
その自我があるんだ あるんだからといったところで
自我を支配しているもう真我があるんじゃないかと
さらに化け物たちの上でもっと巨大な化け物を作る
幻覚を作るんだと だからこの方向性違うということを覚えておいてください
人々の思考の方向性は
この普通の宗教である思考方向性なんです
仏教では全く逆の方向性で考えているんです
ですから 仏道はパティソータガーミと言うんです
パティソータガーミ で
パティっていうのは逆に反対に反対側に
ソータっていうのは流れ
ガーミっていうのは行く
いわゆる流れの反対方向に行くんだと
流れと一緒に行くんじゃなくて
流れっていうのは人々の思考の流れなんですね
執着して輪廻転生する流れなんですね
この真我がある 私がいるという概念がある限りは
輪廻を脱却することはできないんです
なぜならば 何か大事なものがあると思っているんです
私という それで執着が生まれてきて
もう死んでもまた流れが続けていってしまっちゃうんですね
エネルギー消えませんだから
ですから その流れでどんな哲学を作ったっても意味がないんです
解脱の道ではならなくなっちゃうんです
全く逆の流れで考えなくちゃいけないと
いわゆるパティソータガーミという
わざわざとへんてこりんなことを考えるわけではなくて
ちゃんと正しく考えると
人間が流れに沿って考えると思ってますけど
これはみんなへんてこりんなことを考えてるんです
ですから きちんと具体的に正しく考えることを
お釈迦様はパティソータガーミと言うのは人々の考え方に比べて言うんです
でも釈迦尊の考え方はありのまま真実考えるんだから
正見正道なんとか何とかで正しいということをそこで使ってるんですね
八正道だと 正しい道だと ８
種類の まあ一応その我に対して
初期仏教の立場はそういう立場なんです
我が信じるか信じないかというのは
その人の個人の自由であって
それは別に気にしませんと
我が信じる人はずっと輪廻転生して苦しみを続けるし
我を我がないということは発見した人が解脱をするし
それだけのことで だから解脱できるかないかということは
自分がこの我という概念を捨てられるかないかというところにあるんです
で 例えばずっと初期仏教ばっかり考えて勉強している人だったら
無我であるということは当たり前の論理としてわかってます
そんなものは当たり前で
私も小さい頃から無我ということは当たり前だと思っていたんだけど
それは知識なんですね
いくらなんでも 無我であることは体験しなくちゃいけないんですね
体験したらもう全部執着は消えちゃうんです
ですから 知識で無我は徹底的に知っているといえば
テーラワーダ環境で育てる人々というのはみんな知ってるんです
それをもう もうどうしてもその人々に魂があるかと説得することは絶対不可能なほど知ってるんです
笑われるかもしれません
魂なんかあるんだよと言ったら
じゃあそれまで知ってるんだったらって言ったってそうじゃなくて
それはやっぱり思考方法として
お釈迦様のおかげで正しく考えるようになったんだけど
体験しているかいないかっていうことはまた別の話で
この体験っていうのはわざとしなくちゃいけないもので
なぜならば物っていうのは強烈な速さで変化する
ゆっくり変化するんだったらわかるんです
これ 物事というのは光の速度よりすごい速さで心は変化していくんだから
一本で見えてしまっちゃうんです
音っていうのはすごい速さで変化するのに
我々にとっては音楽で聞こえてしまっちゃうんです
あの瞬間瞬間 一秒間で 二十万回
四十万回変化するんです
その変化はわからなくなっちゃうんです
あまりにも早いんだから
例えば同じピアノの曲にしたっても
一つのキーを押して 一秒間待ってて
次のキーを押すと また一秒間
あるいは二 三秒間待っていて
次のキーを押すと そうするとわかりますかね
それはベートーヴェンのなんとかなんとかとか
さっぱりわからないでしょうに
だから楽譜はもうなんとか決まってる有名な楽譜を持ってきて
まずこれ押して 次にこれを押してとか
次にこれとかやっちゃえば音楽じゃないでしょ
そうするとどんな専門家もわからなくなっちゃうんです
あるいはあの人はどんな曲を演奏しているかと
やっぱり速さが必要なんです
その決まってる速さでキーを押す
押すちゃうと あ これなんとか曲だなと頭に耳に入っちゃうんです
ですから 私たちはこの修行として
この決まってる速さでピアノを弾くんじゃなくて
わざとスローモーションにしてみてくださいと
徹底的にスローモーションにしてみてくださいと
そうすると 無常であることを体験の道に心が育って
体験できる道に心が育っていくんです
ですから 瞑想するときでも全部スローモーションでやってくださいというのは
このスローモーションこそ鍵なんです
音は我々にもしかしてスローモーションにすることができたならば
音はないってことはわかるんです
例えば音楽 今もできますけどね
簡単に機械ですから 音楽を糸すれこうして
それはできるだけスローモーションで回してみると
そうすると全然音楽ないでしょう
ものすごいおかしい変な音が出るでしょうに
ですから無常わからないのは
現象は驚異的な速さで変化するんだからなんです
ですから 心を磨いてそれを捕まってみると
この速さを それで無我だと体験できるんですね
それで初めて煩悩は消えるんだと
それでない限りは煩悩は消えないと仏教では断言して言ってるんですね
無常を体験しない限りは煩悩は消えませんと
煩悩が消えないならば解脱はないんだと
そこで解脱はあるのは仏教だけかと聞いたら
いえ そんなことではなくて
法則ですから 誰でも同じことをやったら同じ結果だよと
今はこんなことを言っているのは私だけですよと
もし他の人が同じ無常論を持ってきて同じこと言っちゃったら
また同じ結果なんです
まあ一応それで心の流れの世界が終了して
今日はヴィーティ・ムッタという
この心の流れということではなくて
また理解していかなくちゃいけない
いろいろ仏教のいろんな概念がありまして
そちらの説明に行きます
第五章 そこで覚えやすくするために全部四つ四つに分けているんです
一番目に出てくるのはブーミ・チャトゥッカ
地の四種と で 四つの四つの
四つのカテゴリーが四つあるんです
四つの四つと で その四つの四つと十六にしているのは
別にこのただ覚えやすいするためなんです
だと思います ブーミ・チャトゥッカって何ですかと
この一のところ タッタ・アパーヤ・ブーミ・カーマ・スガタ・ブーミ・ルーパ・アヴィチャラ・ブーミ・アルーパ・アヴィチャラ・ブーミ・チェーティ・チャタッソー・ブーミヨー・ナー
マ
一番目はアパーヤ・ブーミ
それは理然智とか言って
二番目は欲善 欲善 衆智
三番目は色界智 四番目は無色界智
で パーリ語でアパーヤ・ブーミと言うんですが
で とにかくここで言っているのはこの生命の次元なんです
生命の次元たくさんあるんです
時々九つの次元に分けても分けているし
で ですから数はそんなにこの
まあその場でその場で変わるんです
今は四つの次元に分けてるだけであって
で また違う時は まあナマ・サッターワ・サット九つの次元に分ける時もあるし
これ十三にすることもできるし
で そこ だからといって勝手に仏教より偉いことを喋ろうと思って
三十三次元とか四十次元とか喋る大馬鹿もんが日本にいるんだけど
あの人は次元というのことを何ですかと分かってないんです
ただ数字が増えただけで
自分が誰よりも偉いことを知ってるそうということにならないんです
それは信じる人にはそうかもしれませんだけど
知ってる人にはもうあんまりにも
せいぜい人間知ってるのは二次元と三次元だけなんですけど
それも物理的な次元でしょ
我々二次元三次元っていうのは生命の次元じゃないんです
そんなことで次元の数だけ増えたっても意味がないんですけど
で アパーヤ・ブーミ それはこの人間の次元を中心にして考える時
この次元が出てくるんだと
このアパっていうのはもうダウン
下という意味なんですね
成長ではなくて堕落っていう意味なんですね
このアパという言葉 APA
次にあるのはアヤという言葉なんです
アパとアヤとまとめたところでアパーヤというんですね
アヤっていうのは二つ意味があります
一つは道という意味があります
もう一つは門 入り口という意味もあります
あれ口という意味なんですね
道ですね ですから下へ行く道
いわゆる堕落の道っていう意味なんですね